we passed the American Girl doll store
yes and you started to go on and on
about how you had never had you always
wanted one when you were a kid but you
never had one so I stopped and got you
we have a picture here an American Girl
doll wax am NOT as nice as I look I made
you
I made you choose between two of them
and said that I was going to murder the
other one that's what's happening in
that moment that's right you're happy /
upset the other will be incinerated
yeah yeah yeah oh my god I was surprised
it really I thought it well this is kind
of a fun goofy thing to do you were in
love with that dog oh no that like
filled a void in me like you were like
this will be a funny bit for YouTube or
Facebook and I was like no this is this
is healing something I was like I might
quit stand-up now
yeah I've been trying to guess yeah I
mean when I was a kid I mean they're so
expensive
yeah and if you have good parents who
don't want you to be a bad person
they're like we're not gonna get you
spend hundreds of dollars on a doll and
you're like well fine I'm gonna run away
but I never got one and so I'm in the
I'm in the van just proving that I'm a
25 year old girl where everyone's like
what's an American girl that I'm like
well they're not just dolls there are
books yeah and Phil yes yeah everything
are we at the hotel yet you knew every
single doll and her history I did yeah
we're doing scary
[Music]